You mentioned last night when we were having dinner that when you first got the job as CEO,...
...you got a call from Steve Jobs and he offered you some advice?
Well, he didn't call to offer me advice,...
...but we have worked together on a Nike - Apple collaboration called Nike Plus.
So, we took what Apple knows, what Nike knows and, you know, brought a new technology to the market.
Anyway, long story short, he said, "Hey, congratulations."
"It's great."
"You're gonna do a great job."
I said, "Well, do you have any advice?"
And he said, "No, no. You're great."
And then there was a pause...
...and he goes, "Well, I do have some advice."
He goes, "Nike makes some of the best product in the world."
"I mean, product that you lust after, absolutely beautiful, stunning product."
"But you also make a lot of crap."
He said, "Just get rid of the crappy stuff and focus on the good stuff."
And then I expected a little pause and a laugh,...
...but there was a pause but no laugh at the end.
Yeah.
And he was absolutely right.
And in fact, that's one of my major focal points in terms of my priorities as a CEO...
...and even as a designer when I was growing up at the company, is to edit.
We have so many ideas.
Nike is an idea factory.